novich i hope i pronounced your name
correctly miss love
uh yeah that's correct okay and mislove
is
a phd student at eth uh with martin
vetcher
and he has done some very nice work in
applying machine learning to smt solvers
and solvers in general
so without further ado miss love the
floor is yours
please go ahead thanks for the
introduction
uh also thanks for an invitation to
speak at this workshop
i hope you can see my slides uh today i
will tell you about
the work that we did on uh learning how
to synthesize
strategies for smt solvers uh so this
was work that we presented at
eurips 2018 uh and it was joint work
with
my colleagues at tth powell and martin
so i guess everybody here is familiar
with smt solvers but
let me just give you an example uh
anyway
so there is a formula phi which consists
of three variables
here and uh some set of constraints
and then our question is to find an
assignment to all the free variables
such that
this formula evaluates to true and as we
know the
standard tool to solve such a problem is
an smt
solver so once we give this
logic formula phi to the smt solver as
an
input then the solver will produce
either the assignment to this variable
so that formula is true
which is called the model or it will
provide a proof that the formula is
unsatisfiable
so of course we also know that solving
this problem in full generality is very
hard
for example just looking at the
quantifier free boolean subset
of the smt we know that it's mp
complete so we cannot hope to actually
solve
this in full generality
however what we actually care about in
practice
is that users have some specific
applications that they want to
use smt for such as software
verification
or program synthesis and then for these
applications
users convert them to the smt formulas
and run smt solvers on those
and now the developers of smt solvers
they crafted some very smart heuristics
which tend to perform well very well in
this practical settings that
arise from such applications
and then once we have some formula
then the key question is which heuristic
to apply
so given a formula phi then what
smt solar does is that it goes through
the list of
possible heuristics and then examines
the formula so it checks
whether the formula is in some theory
and it also checks properties like how
many variables there are
in the formula and then based on these
properties it picks one of the
heuristics
and if this this is chosen well then the
solar will
terminate quickly with an answer set to
run set
so this is what is what happens in
practice
however one drawback with uh with this
is that
if you are an user and you have some new
benchmark that
you want to run so you want to solve
your benchmark
then it may easily perform badly on your
own problem
and the reason is that these heuristics
in smt solars they are
designed quite well to cover wide range
of scenarios so
they work on wide range of benchmarks
but
uh if you really want to solve just your
benchmark
and solve it well then you maybe want
something tailored to your own benchmark
and another issue is that if you
actually run this
on your benchmark and uh it doesn't work
that well then
uh you may need to go deep into the
heuristics
of the solver and look into the
implementation and try to fix it
but this may require expert knowledge
and
this these two problems can actually
limit wider adoption
of these tools and here in this work we
want to address this
so one paper that motivated our approach
is uh called the strategy challenge in
smt solving
where the authors um asked
s t community to try to develop some
methods through which users can control
these heuristic aspects of smt solars
and then this motivated us to look
actually into the
machine learning approach to this
problem where we would fully automate
this so user would supply some formulas
and then we would learn
strategies that actually perform well on
these formulas
so that is the workfast smt which we
presented at
eurips so let me just give brief
overview of the setup
so we assume that user has some set of
formulas that they want to solve
and then they would run fast smt
on some of these formulas and
what fast smt would do is it would learn
some strategies that
sold many of these formulas and sold
them as quickly as possible
and then we can once we have this then
we can just plug it in the existing
solver
and use it instead of the default
strategy
and now if this is done well then it
would work
nicely for the for the problem and
one important thing is here that we will
assume no prior knowledge of the
internal strategies used by the existing
solvers so we want to be fully general
but of course we will assume knowledge
of the building blocks of these
strategies
which are called tactics which i will
explain later
so this is the overall this is the goal
we will
try to achieve so
how does smt solver actually apply this
tactics so what smt solver does is that
it starts with some formula phi
and then it decides to apply some
transformation which
revise the formula or partially solves
it
so we can see here that the solver
applies tactic t1
and then it arrives at the new formula
phi 1
and then it is done repeatedly so solver
chooses some tactic
and then transforms the formula using
this tactic
until in the end we obtain formula that
is trivially
satisfiable or trivially unsatisfiable
and
in that case we are done so
let me give some examples of heuristics
in this in the
solvers for example constant folding
heuristic
exploits the fact that addition of zero
in integer theory
can be omitted because it has no effect
normalization of the bounds can
introduce
a variable substitution so that left
hand side of the inequality
is equal to zero which can
simplify solving then bit blasting can
change the representation
from integer to bit vector and
there are many more of these such
tactics
there are overall around 100 of such
tactics in
z3 solver in this work we will
treat all of these actions as black
boxes
so this these tactics will be just some
actions for us
and uh we will not assume any knowledge
of the internal workings of the
strategies
uh good thing about this is that then if
somebody implements a new tactic
then it can be easily integrated into
our framework
another key ingredient that smt solvers
enable
are using predicates so
what we can do is we can given a formula
phi we can evaluate some predicate p
on that formula and then based on
whether the
predicate is true or false we choose
either tactic t1 or tactic t2
for example we can check whether the
number of atoms in the formula is less
than 10 and in that case
we choose tactic t1 and otherwise we
choose t2
and this allows smt solar to have great
flexibility
because otherwise it would just be able
to apply same sequence of tactics
to all of the formulas and there are
many of these formula measures that we
can use to build up the predicate such
as number of atoms or the formula size
and we can also have conjunctions and
disjunctions
of these rules
so here is an example of a real strategy
implemented in
solaris where the predicate checks
whether the formula is not in a
difference fragment
and whether the number of inequalities
divided by number of
uninterpreted constants is below some
threshold k
and if it is then we choose simplex
algorithm
and otherwise we choose floyd marshall
algorithm
so this is one of the heuristics that
was
handcrafted by the developers of this
smt solver
and in this work our goal will be to
automatically learn
straight strategies like this and
uh of course we will not learn the this
strategy but we will learn strategy that
works best for the set of formulas that
the user is interested in
so once we want to do that
we can look at this bigger picture where
what we want to do
is that for each formula we want to
choose some tactic to apply
but if you look at this search tree then
we can see that
since it is exponential then there are
too many paths that which can
which we can take so for example here we
can take the green path
and solve the formula in 12 seconds or
we can take
yellow path and solve the formula in 500
seconds
or we can take red path and not solve
the formula at all
so hand crafted strategy inside the
solver
it just determines one of these paths
but this may not
necessarily be the optimal one and we
want to learn a policy which will
actually select
uh the optimal path so in this case we
want to learn a policy that will select
the green path
so we know that the smt solver now is
instantiated by
a formula and the strategy which is the
sequence of tactics
so one simple idea that we may do is we
may just have a model which receives
formula as an input
and then given this formula it outputs
the entire strategy and once we have the
strategy we just
instantiate it with the solar
so one problem with this approach is
that it may actually be hard to learn
this
because this strategy can be quite long
and then
if the model makes one mistake so makes
one
wrong tactic then the solution may fail
solving of the formula may fail and the
model will not get any feedback at all
so this approach would be quite tricky
to make it work
but let's now go back to this example
and let's again look at this search tree
so what we can observe is that this is
very similar to
reinforcement learning setting so in
reinforcement learning
we have states actions and rewards so
naturally our states would be
corresponding to the current formula
that we have
our actions would correspond to the
tactics that we can apply
to the formula and our rewards would be
dependent on
how long it takes for us to solve the
formula
and once we have once we defined these
three ingredients
states actions and rewards then we can
actually
more easily leverage concepts from
machine learning to
learn um the best strategy
so this is how it would look after we
after we apply this obstruction
from two states actions and rewards
and our goal is to learn the optimal one
and difference with the other approach
now we have a
we started a formula five and then we
query our policy to give us the next
tactic
so it would give us tactic t1 we would
pass it to the smt solver
and smt solar would modify our formula
to phi 1
and this would be done repeatedly so
each time policy produces
a new tactic and smt solver applies this
tactic to the formula
and until in the end the obtained
formula which is trivially
satisfiable will run satisfiable and in
that case we are done
so this is of course much easier to
learn because now the policy just has to
output next tactic
and not all strategy at once
however there are also some drawbacks
for example we lose the internal snt
state
for example if we started with the
integer
representation x equals to 5 and we
applied
bit vector bit blasting to turn into bit
vector representation
then smt solver will not be able to
remember this because of this decoupling
between
the policy and smt and we will not be
able to get the model in the end
um and another problem is that we will
have some runtime overhead
because at every step yes we need to
query the policy
and policy can be actually some quite
expensive model
such as a neural network and
so we can see that there are still some
issues with even if we can
learn a very good policy there is still
this issue that
we have to address
but we can actually use this learning
process that we have
as a first step so given some set of
formulas we can perform
learning and i will describe
in the next slide what we do for
learning
but imagine that we have some procedure
to learn the policy
so once we have this policy we will use
uh something we call policy extraction
so we will extract uh strategy from this
policy
and strategy will be written in the
language of snt strategies so recall
that
this language of smt strategies uses
some specific predicates
and conditionals like it checks for the
number of atoms
and so on so this means that you cannot
rely on neural network anymore
so we need to convert this uh kind of
uninterpretable model such as neural
network
into a strategy that is uh written in
this
language of strategies that solver has
but if we manage to do this
then we can just plug in the strategy in
the solver
instead of the default one so we just
replace it
and now this is very tight integration
with the existing solver
now if we want to get the model or onset
core
this can be easily done we can
essentially use all of the features of
the solar
and there is no runtime overhead so now
we do not need to query the policy
at every step so these are the two
components that i will describe next
learning and policy extraction
and after we have this then we can
actually
apply our approach in practice
so the key component of
learning procedure is the policy and
policies essentially
can be any function that receives us an
input the formula
and it outputs
next tactic to apply and we tried
several different models and what we
found works best for us
is the following so it consists of three
parts
first we give it as an input some
the list of tactics that were applied to
get to the current formula
so this is useful because then we can
learn that some tactic is only efficient
after some other tactic is applied
before
then another feature is formula measure
such as
we can evaluate number of constants or
whether the formula belongs to some
theory
and we extract these features and
all we can also compute some formula
representation such
as peg of words or abstract syntax tree
this helps if you want to count for
example how many additions
occur in the formula so we can embed
all of these features and these are all
features that will be helpful to decide
what next tactic to choose and after
this is embedded it can be passed
through some
model which is some neural network for
us
and this model now has kind of two heads
as outputs
uh first head gives probability
distribution over tactics so in this
example it would predict that with 70
chance the best tactic to apply now is p
pb to bv
and it also outputs parameters for this
tactics
so each tactic can have some number of
parameters such as
a number of steps in some algorithm
so after i describe the policy how do we
actually train this
end to end that's the next question
so we start with the set of formulas
that the user has
and now we can initialize policy
randomly and even just this random
policy can be used to sample some
strategies
and most of them are going to fail but
some of them will manage to solve the
formula
although they will take quite a long
time
but we can still use those strategies to
build up a training data set
and this training data set essentially
is
we look at the search tree that we
explore so far and then we look at each
node
in hindsight what would have been the
best action to take
in this node and i will give you more
details in the next slide
but once we build up this data set we
can actually retrain the policy
so that it takes this best action in
hindsight
and after we retraining the policy
then uh it would perform much better and
this training can be done using
combination of cross entropy laws to
predict the next tactic
and mean squared loss to predict the
parameters
so after we retrain the policy
then we can actually use it to sample
again
so we sample new strategies which will
hopefully be better than
the ones from the random random policy
and we improve our data set and then
retrain the policies so this continues
again
until we are satisfied with our policy
or we run out of time
so this is the end-to-end training
procedure
so here is an example of a data set
so in this data set essentially
we have on the left side we have a
formula
that we explored so far and
for each formula we know that we know
the best tactic to apply so for example
for the middle row formula phi 3 we know
that with 80
probability the next best tactic is t1
so when we build this data set then we
can fit policy pi
uh so we can fit neural networks to this
data set
and now this policy will generalize to
the new states
and this really is the key reason why we
use machine learning
because the this model will be able to
pick up some patterns from this data set
that we explored so far
and then once it ends up in some part of
the search tree that it has not explored
yet
it will be able to generalize these
patterns and it will be able to guide
itself to
the optimal strategy in this part of
this
part of the tree that that it has not
seen before
so so that is the basic promise of
machine learning that
we're building on
okay so so far i told you how we get
how we learn this policy which produces
an action given a state and we can use
it to
run it on a bunch of formulas and for
each formula we get
a list we get some strategy some
sequential strategy
but we remember that we still need to do
the next step which looks at this search
tree
and then when there is a in this tree of
strategies
and then for each node which has
multiple outgoing edges
we need to uh make a decision which
action to choose
so this is something that we still need
to do
and let me just give a sketch of what we
can do
for example here we are at some node and
then we have four formulas five one to
four
and four strategies s1 to s4
and uh each strategy solves some of the
formulas but
no strategy solves all of the formulas
and
we want to choose some predicate in the
allowed language of the s
t solver so that it splits the formulas
into two sets
and then each of the subsets can be
solved by the same strategy
so here we can observe that formulas 5 1
and 4
are quite similar they can be stalled by
the same strategies
and similarly phi 2 and 3 can be solved
by the same strategies
so ideally we want to find a predicate
which evaluates to true for
formulas 5 1 and 4 and to false for uh
formulas phi 2 and 3.
and this is of course perfect scenario
but in practice we just need some metric
that given a predicate it
evaluates how good how good is this
split obtained by the
predicate and this will be some
heuristic
and we will use something similar to
decision trees
uh for the people who are familiar with
this
essentially we will define entropy of
the set of formulas
where we sum up over all strategies and
then we look
uh essentially for
how many formulas that these strategies
solve and build up this
entropy formula based on this so here we
would split
based on this predicate c
which would have perfect entropy of zero
by splitting into
the blue set and the yellow set of
formulas
so so far i described this um
so now i described also the second part
where we
extract the strategy from already
learned strategies
and now that i describe both components
of our algorithm
then let's look at the evaluation
so in the evaluation we are going to
compare to the state-of-the-art
zgsmt solver and we will compare on five
benchmarks from smt competitions so for
for each of the competitions
we will first run learning procedure so
the first part of our algorithm
to learn a set of strategies and then we
will extract
a police will attract strategy some
specific strategy from this policy
so that's the second part i was
describing and once we have this
strategy we can plug it into the z3 and
measure the
speed up and measure how many more
formulas we managed to solve
so we are comparing z3 now with two
versions one version is default one with
a default strategy
and another one is with our strategy
and we can show this in this kind of
graph where
we evaluate on 100 formulas
and for each formula we measure speed up
which is shown
on the y-axis in log scale
and so this horizontal line at one is
our baseline so that's the z3
default strategy and everything above
one means that we are faster
than it and everything below one means
that
we are slower so when we evaluate this
edge to benchmark
we get quite good results and we can
observe two
main things so first we are always above
one so this means that for all of the
formulas
we are actually faster and
another thing is that if you look at the
median so
the median speed up at 50 uh this means
that for at least half of the formulas
we are at least 10x faster than the
default strategy
and for some benchmarks our we get even
higher uh
improvements and there are of course
some benchmarks
uh where there are formulas where
default strategy does quite well
and uh it does better than us but even
there we still improve on lots of
formulas
and um another thing i want to emphasize
is that
our approach starts from scratch so we
essentially
don't start at this horizontal line with
one but we start at the line which says
zero
and we still managed to improve uh over
the
default strategy so this is quite nice
and another thing that we can measure
here is the
number of formulas that we solve so once
we combine our strategies into one
using the second part of our approach
and plug it into the z3 solver
then we can compare with the default
strategy and
on these five benchmarks that we
consider and we can see that
we can solve many form we can solve many
more formulas in some cases
for example on stage 2 benchmark we can
solve 500 more formulas than the default
strategy
so we can steal that we can see that
here
we also get quite nice improvements
and i also want to briefly remark that
this approach can be generalized also to
improve some other tools and not just
smt solvers
so we also
in our ccs19 paper we use similar
approach to learn how to test ethereum
programs
with fuzzing so there essentially you
want to generate
some test cases for the ethereum
programs and
a tactic corresponds to tactics here
corresponds to function call in that
program and strategy corresponds to some
sequence of function calls and then you
want to
learn a strategy that achieves highest
code coverage and discovers as many bugs
as possible
so this is this was quite nice example
of how
we could apply similar learning strategy
in
uh two different settings
and so i told you about our approach to
learn
smt strategies which consisted of
two components a learning component
which uh
i described first which gives a policy
to
select the next tactic in the sequence
and the policy extraction component
which produces a strategy that can be
plugged into the solar
and um so all of our materials
are open source and can be found on our
website our code is on github
and with this i would like to conclude
my talk
uh thanks for the attention and i'm here
for any questions that
you may have thank you miss love for a
very nice and clear talk
very good um moshe you have some
questions
uh it's more of a comment that again
very nice very nice work
i think this idea that we need to take a
going from a
like deep reinforcement learning towards
say some kind of a
code extra code that we can use
other than just a deep model
this has been exploring also in other
contexts and i'll i'll send you some
references
work there was a phd student a tristan
qt
abinav varma there's a look at different
application but
also did kind of the same thing use a
deep learning
but then transform it to to code because
it
it gives you many properties for example
expandability is much better
with code than it is with some deep tip
model
yeah exactly that's right so there are
there are also several other settings or
where this is uh quite important to do
thanks so uh i have a couple of
questions so
i'm assuming that the strategy that you
extract at the end
the overhead due to it is quite minimal
it's the same as
the default strategy right
uh exactly so default strategy may be
somewhat shorter
because it's uh crafted by humans
but we observe that there is no overhead
essentially by plugging in
our strategy
and um if i were to
uh you know kind of extend this
idea to um
so if a user were to want to use this
they could use the default strat
or the your strategy that you trained
using your tool the fastest empty tool
but then uh but if that doesn't work
well they will probably have to go
through the same series of steps so they
just use your tools to do the
learning and the policy extraction and
then augment the
the strategy program uh so you mean uh
that
they would essentially first try our
strategy and then
if it doesn't work then they can try the
default one
right but uh it's possible that the
their set of formulas
are quite different from the formulas
that you trained on they're kind of out
of distribution if you will
so therefore yeah yeah exactly so the
idea is that kind of user when they have
some set of formulas let's say they have
10 000 formulas that they want to solve
and then they
train on some small subset of this
formulas and learn
strategy that works best for them so the
strategies that i described in
our experiments they will not work
probably for uh specific applications
that
users can have so they need to retrain
on their data
right uh any other questions
if not i thank mislove again for a very
nice and clear talk
thank you and i hope it's not too late
wherever you are the next speaker
is my great pleasure to introduce
professor kevin leyton brown
uh